Black voters were obviously key
to President Biden being elected in
2020 and polls have shown
that his support
among young black Americans has softened.
How worrying is that
or should that be
for the president's reelection prospects
Look, I think the lesson
is that no group with young voters,
whether it's black voters,
whether it's Latino voters,
whether it's women voters,
whether it's any voter wants to be frank
and you have to work on it
and you have to work on
it's still not just a few weeks
before the election.
I think the Biden campaign understands
that that is why he is at Howard
giving that speech today,
because it's basically an admission
of the importance of that vote.
As you know,
the speeches,
the commencement speeches that a
president and Vice gives are
and are
curated and I think
and this is a reason for that.
And honor back to the Republican field
and what's happening in Iowa
this weekend.
We heard our
our colleague
Steve Caetano
saying that
DeSantis does not appear
to be wanting to go after Trump
this weekend,
that he's
avoiding these direct attacks on Trump,
almost certainly
because he fears alienating
that that Trump base,
our Republican base.
What do you make of that strategy?
Look, Sanchez
is going to have to do something.
I think he hasn't
come into the race before
because the legislative session
was going on in Florida.
That legislative session ended last week,
and he's still signing
some of the bills that were passed.
But I also think DeSantis
has done himself
an enormous amount of harm
in this legislative session
and in the last few months in Florida,
he has shown himself
to be the type of person
who weaponize his government,
whether it's against a drag branch
or against Disneyworld.
And that is costing him.
Floridians don't like that.
And I think the number
that's got to be worrying
DeSantis
the most
is the fact that his support has dropped
not just nationally,
but in the state of Florida,
where we see him most
and where we know him best.
And that is something
that should be of great concern to him.
Scott, I want to get your thoughts
on the flip side of that.
And President Trump focusing primarily
on Ron DeSantis,
despite the fact
that there are others in the field,
namely Nikki Haley, Asa Hutchinson.
What do you make of that tactic?
Well, I mean,
the reality is all
these other candidates
are virtually nowhere.
If you look at the polling,
they're all in low single digits.
They just don't carry
the same positive name I.D.
And the Republican Party of the Santos.
He's the only one in double digits.
If Trump
a Trump thinks that,
he could go ahead and dispatch DeSantis.
Now, none of these other people
are ever going to be able to rise up
and consolidate
the entire Trump lane of the party,
or at least the people
who want to do something else.
Maybe they don't dislike Trump,
but maybe they think
we need a new nominee.
So dispatching DeSantis
before he ever really
gets out of the gate
which he is working very diligently
on, obviously is priority one for Trump.
And there's some evidence
that it's working at the moment.
But I wouldn't count out DeSantis.
There's a lot
a lot of runway left in the race.